as we have seen here in the past year so
lake mead really becoming a very popular
place
to be with family and enjoy the great
outdoors but with so many people at the
beach or maybe boating there have been
accidents and even loss of life some
preventable
just by wearing a life jacket it's
necessary last saturday six-year-old
stacy mock drowned at lake mead
when the float she was on was blown into
deeper water by the intense winds
she could not get back to shore
kimbrough joining us now live from the
lake in madison a fishing club is
actually the one who's trying
to raise money for more life jackets
being available at the lake right
yes it is expected to be very warm here
this weekend it's mother's day weekend
so if you are out enjoying the lake as
you can see we are here
or in the near future it's important to
know what to bring and be aware of
when you are out on the water even if
you're a good swimmer
the waves that occur in a
in the lake are a lot different than the
waves that you encounter in your pool
they never stop they're unrelenting
while they are fun to float on
pool floats are for the pool nick duhay
with the nevada department of wildlife
says
bringing these toys to the lake is not
recommended the wind will catch
those pool toys those pool rafts catch
an edge
blow it up flip it over blow it away
and if that doesn't cause the problem
what happens is
it starts to go away people try to go
out and swim and catch it
usually places like boulder beach have
life vests to use but the problem is
they don't get returned dusty fazell
runs a facebook page
las vegas fishing club they started
raising money so more life jackets can
be made available
people just don't know that you can get
life jackets
in different setup locations throughout
the lake
so awareness to that as well as
providing more jackets because people do
take them we've raised five thousand
two hundred dollars for life jackets so
lake mead can have more jackets
on the water according to fazel the park
rangers at lake mead are working to get
10 thousand dollars to go towards new
life jackets
and bass pro shops plan to donate 2
thousand dollars
and life jackets do expire so it's
important that you are wearing one that
is properly inflated and
fitted and you know the weather can
change rather quickly